the Joe Rogan experience what's the
ceiling on this like if if they can can
continue to grow I mean it's it's really
is it possible that we're looking at a
country that might be completely run and
overrun by criminal organizations and
drug sellers some parts of it are
already so what I think is gonna happen
is you'll see escalations a clear sign
or a clear group that is like a sign of
things to come is the is a new
generation cartel the new generation
cartel is a cartel that was it used to
be called laws amatis etis there was
basically an armed enforcing group that
Sinaloa cartel made to go after their
main rivals the set does which were
originally members of special Mexican
special forces that said you know what
we're gonna be cartel guys
oh now in cartel enforcers now so they
whole sordid history the it was a
militarized group that was formed formed
to go after them right and their whole
kind of play was that we're gonna be
against extortion against abducting
people against the affecting the
community we're gonna enforce the law in
our communities but we're also gonna
move drugs through here right but that
you know that's kind of their thing so
you see this group started kind of
growing in the region and right now it's
pretty big its rivaling the Sinaloa
cartel as far as power and reach but the
way they do their things is militarized
it's very militaristic and kind of
paramilitary and it kind of reminds me a
little bit about of the like the the
FARC groups in Colombia hearts and minds
they go into the communities that
community policing in the area that he
originally said you know we're where the
government wants to fight drugs here in
the region we agree with their fight but
we are also going to fight against these
guys that are affecting community as
well and they have like groups of people
they have they have training camps no
medical militaristic trading camps where
they recruit people they take them there
and they're being trained in gorilla
warfare and shooting and apparently
there's some SF guys from the US that
advise
so that's the that's the next thing the
escalation of a simple ragtag group of
cartel guys enforcing a region to an
actual cohesive paramilitary group now
trying to vie for control not just of
the of the drug routes but also have the
populace and the confidence of the
populace as and so it could turn
political at some point right it just
seems like it's the genies out of the
bottle it hit I mean it is I mean it
isn't a lot of ways you know and going
after it just as a you know drug
enforcement issue it's not you know
there's so much bigger than that yeah
it's a cultural it's an economic you
know some of these kids
I've got posted up some of these cartels
sold your kids at twelve years old
plated guns gold plated guns you know
they don't have a knob they don't have
options in their life right it's that or
nothing
right it's either awesome life or short
Austrian poverty short awesome life yeah
a short awesome life or extreme poverty
so that's when a component to it another
component is systemic corruption as a
society from who knows when you know
it's always been a thing in Mexico
people that grew up down there you get
stopped at a red light and you're like
can I pay the fine here you know people
that are from now there will be aware of
this yeah show you the chill the
paperwork you slide that thing in there
you know that's you know that's part of
the culture that's affecting a lot of
things as well you know people don't pay
attention to the small rules or the big
rules don't matter right and just being
next to the largest drug market on the
planet you know and having money
firearms rounds going down and fentanyl
that it's being fabricated in Mexico now
and some of the Chinese fentanyl making
its way through into the u.s. kind of
filling the voids that some of the drug
market has right now so they're making
fentanyl laced fake fentanyl laced pills
they're going to be they're being put
into US and fentanyl laced heroin right
so that's where they're going towards
now that's why you see this epidemic up
here and a lot of things traditionally
kind of focused on
pot before it was legalized in a lot of
arenas up here now is heroin and
fentanyl so it's actually kind of
accelerated the production of the more
harmful and dangerous drugs in some ways
yes
I mean they had to find another you know
it was it went pot meth and now
fentanyl-laced heroin or fentanyl laced
pills see in the problem with the idea
of legalization is that if you tried to
be the person who says hey folks we need
to legalize drugs here in America
because we've got this problem with the
cartels politically that suicide yeah no
no one I mean even though it's probably
right it is I think it is I think it is
very right it's one of those things
that's so counterintuitive that most
people are gonna go you're crazy you're
gonna make my kids hooked on drugs well
I'll say this I was I've fought in the
drug war I literally a drug war veteran
yeah and if I had a white flag I would
hand it over to you you know it's like I
that this it's a useless fight I got to
destroy pot fields realistically
thinking about all the effort and all
the blood I'm like yeah and it's so
quick to grow back I mean that it it is
it is a fruitless fight fentanyl
heroin maybe different drugs fentanyl in
particulars but a lot of that fentanyl
is coming from China oh yeah a lot of
people that are making or producing
fentanyl in places like Mexico are from
China
setting up laboratories in Mexico so
it's a it's a Chinese Mexican us problem
as well god damn what can be done other
than the legalization what could be done
I mean how does and unless the United
States literally goes to war with the
Mexican cartels and you made a face I
mean I'd say designation is one of what
I think that's a nation should it's it's
going to happen a terrorist designation
it's gonna happen I mean again we just
saw the murder the massacre of Mexican
they were dual citizenship nine people
kids women it's not uncommon for that
to happen to Mexican nationals it's
pretty uncommon for that to happen to
American nationals down there
and that woke up woke up a bunch of
people you know mm-hmm and now he's
another recent murder of another
American national you know kid with his
parents down there you know people will
say just don't go down Mexico but but
some of these people you know live down
there and have family down there and
have communities down there it's just
ultra violent you know that people have
to wake up on this side to realize this
problem is not gonna get any better
this problem is not just a Mexican
problem it's a US Mexican problem and
you know it'll get to a point where it's
gonna be you know I think in my lifetime
it's gonna be some sort of armed
intimate intervention in Mexico at some
point really
so you anticipate almost like in a civil
war I think something's gonna happen in
Mexico is going to destabilize it so
much that the u.s. won't have another
option but to put boots on the ground
probably that's I think that's that's
where we're headed the problem and again
another of the problems is that the
government is part of the problem so you
can go down there and negotiate with
this government but six years later it's
gonna be another government you got to
renegotiate with them yeah and also use
you palm grease yeah and then you put
all your faith in the military and the
military gets compromised you put all
the fate and the Mexican Marines and
then they get compromised and now who do
you have all right so it's systemic
don't tell that to trump he'll use as an
excuse we can't count on them we're
going in
[Applause]